it's my mic on somebody give me a thumbs
up if you can hear me because I can't
hear okay great um that works really
well because I can't see you anyway so
the first letter on this repository link
here is a tea I will share it again I
also tweeted it out my name is Katherine
mean I work at a company called spark
box I'm a full-stack developer or
whatever that means
I use she/her pronouns spark box is a
little web shop in Ohio we have about 40
people I spend most of my time working
on an enterprise level design system you
can ask me about later so today I'm
going to share with you a few tools and
techniques to make your pull request
more effective and more collaborative
because of time I hope to do a quick
summary of a few tools and you can
google them later after the event most
of these tools are not github exclusive
so I've met people from git lab and
bitbucket here and I know there's at
least one github person so hopefully
like you still find something even if
github is not your main technology to
start I should share a bit about context
and how SPARC box does code reviews we
steer north store nearly all of our code
on github we do have one bitbucket
client now that's kind of new we use
shared repositories dedicated to
whatever engagement we're working on
developers have whenever developers have
new code to add to the project they ask
another developer for a code review via
pull request I've come up with six sort
of rules that spark box adheres to while
using github and I will just say that I
came up with these rules for the spark
box process so I do not represent the
thoughts and ideas of my employer yes
rule number one is no one merges their
own code spark box likes to avoid the
concept of a developer island where one
developer is writing emerging all of the
code for a piece of a website last year
we had a cot lion who wanted an
additional full-time developer for a
side project but they would be the only
developer on that project we offered
instead to developers at half time
having a reviewer is that important to
us the second rule is
is never pushed directly to master
pushing directly to master is the
easiest way to break everything
requiring code review re reinforces the
quality that we've come to value as a
company third rule if you're working
with you I get a design review at work
box we have a position called a front
end designer on every project we design
this special designer often will write
front-end code so they may do some CSS
but not every company has designers who
know how to code and nor should they but
that's probably a different talk rule
number four if you are working on copy
get a get a copy review at spark box
this is usually the project manager or
the client themselves we have an
integrated development process so the
clients usually have access to the
repositories we're working on rule
number five is never ever push directly
to master again unless you messed up
which if you did find a buddy to pair
with which leads me to rule number six
which is these rules are more like
guidelines and I made them up but if you
follow these six rules it ensures that
we follow the basic spark mark spree
Creed which is working together for a
web built right if every piece of code
has at least two people contributing to
it
we often catch mistakes before they
happen so all of that is context for
about what I'm about to talk about it
may be different for you and your
company it's just how we like to work so
I'm not telling you how you should do
code reviews some challenges of
collaboration are getting a PR review
from a non coder or getting a PR review
from someone who's in a different time
zone currently I am five hours separate
from most of my team and nine hours
separated from the rest it's not that
easy working with developers who may be
only doing reviews on your project or
working with people who are assigned
directly to PR review and nothing else
so how do we improve these things so I'm
going to give you six steps I think I
guess I like
number six tip number one is write good
stories to ensure good pull requests we
have to write good issues at spark box
we often use and hub github projects
your our Trello to organize engagements
usually with something like scrum which
involves creating stories which is
usually a github issue representing a
bite-sized chunk of work so let's hope
these pictures were great all right
story should include the requirements of
the work and potentially a solution if
you have one in mind story or issue
doesn't need to be overly complicated
but it should be easy to understand a
well-written story makes for a clear
requirements when it comes time to do a
PR and this leads you to my very first
tool recommendation the only one then is
github exclusive but I'm sure there's
something similar on the other
technologies just for reference in the
photo this is my coworker Austin who is
a project manager explaining that
there's this footer it's not great so
maybe we can use some of these other
colors instead so github issue and
github issue templates and PR templates
allow you to add a markdown file to your
root directory to outline the issue
process I'll show you this link again in
a minute this is an issue template
here's my markdown it's included
directly in my project in addition to
adding the template file to the root of
your project you can also include it via
github directory PR templates are also a
thing that can go in this directory they
work the same way but have a different
file name and they come up when you do a
PR instead of an issue so here is the
issue template on github when I click
the new issue button the text field
populates with the contents of the
template file and then these example
files are stored in the repo I linked at
the beginning and I tweet it out and
I'll link at the end I think if you want
to take a closer look talk with your
project team to decide what you should
put into a template mine is just an
example it's very flat example but a
checklist is usually nice you can go
through and click things off so there's
that link again I'll give you about
thirty seconds three seconds two seconds
alright tip number two is get the basics
right
a good way to frustrate your pull
request reviewer is to send them
something with absolutely no context you
could respond in kind these are real
real PRS people from my co-workers the
great uhm but a few extra minutes to
write a thoughtful PR description can go
a long way toward easing the work of the
reviewer we try to include a quick
summary of the work being done usually
matching your commit descriptions linked
to any github issues or stories
especially use it if you're using
something like Zen hub or JIRA for agile
a link or screenshot of the original
design work if you're working on UI as a
developer I love screenshots in addition
to design files because I don't have to
open up Zeppelin every single time I'm
looking at something to build and
step-by-step testing instructions
including how to run the linter or how
to run the tests how to navigate to any
new work how specifically your new work
is meant to function so here's that PR
example again this is from my other
co-worker Bryan he's had a number of
these tips they should be written in the
context of the developer reviewing the
work for example a PR to a developer
who's only doing review or QA may look
completely different to the one who
wrote the build process alright next tip
enhance your pull request with gifts
this is my favorite gift because it's
cat and the cat is coding oh my name is
cat and I'm a coder so it's me I hope
you like that joke it's my only one so
what if a gift can be more than a quick
laughs gifts are awesome for showing nav
functionality transitions hover effects
animation - pretty much any visual
aspect of your work where a front-end
shop can you tell gifts are especially
useful for getting a design review of an
anime
or hover from someone who may not have a
site running locally here is my tool for
this one it's called record it there's
the link it's record it co record it is
a screencasting service that lets you
save your finished recording as a gif
and even gives you a hosted link an
example use case is foundry which is a
spark box blog the CMS that this foundry
is built upon is a really big deal to
set up it may take a full day especially
if it's for a designer a project manager
who's just trying to review one or two
lines of code or comic content by
including a gif you may give the
necessary context and allow everyone to
feel a little confident in what they are
approving so this is just a gif I made
of some functionality so here's the link
to record it again
a downside to record it is that it
doesn't currently support HTTPS which
means as you may know that it can't be
embedded directly into a PR on github it
can still be sent as a slack link or
just an email or whatever
an alternative I've recently discovered
gift box if Fox is a native app it
creates gifts and you can drop them into
github to host them just like you would
an image hosting on github gives you the
full security of your repository so
you're not violating your security
policies it does cost $5 wow this one's
really off
include it is included in set app if
you're a set app subscriber and I think
this one only works on Mac but there are
lots of giving tools out there it's sort
of the thought that counts all right the
next one is enhancing your pull requests
with video an important aspect of a
complicated PR is the ability to walk
someone through your code in the current
age devs are often distributed or remote
we work in different time zones and have
busy schedules sometimes it is nearly
impossible to schedule the 30 minutes to
step through your PR here's the tool
it's go video by video vidyard this used
to be called viewed it they changed it
right after I wrote my talks so I had to
change it
and go video is a Chrome extension they
also have a native app because not
everyone is a fan of Chrome hello and
was it last go video lets a user record
their screen their face and their voice
all at once
specifically we used a video project
like this on engagement where the main
reviewer me was not dedicated to the
project full time because I was not
available for stand-ups I didn't have a
direct hand in building the website and
I wasn't really familiar with the
changes being reviewed the dev had to
explain every change for every PR go
video is one of my new favorite ways to
start a code review I've made you a
video instead of showing you how it's
done hopefully works I keep meaning to
rerecord this but people tell me that
awkwardness is endearing so just just go
with it
hey there github purse this is go video
by viddy art as you can see it records
my entire screen plus a little me down
in the corner over here hello but I
think is super friendly and great for
doing video walkthroughs of pull
requests here you can see that I am on a
pull request and I can go into my file
changes I can look at the code I can
explain hey this class adds 3 M of
padding bottom to our smart box homepage
it hopefully fixes an issue I hope you
like it please merge it obviously I did
merge it because this is me and then
when you are done recording your video
you can go on to a screen one shows up
like this you can see that you can
change your title like cat is super
great at videos you should try it
sometime it's not that great just
kidding that's a bad joke so you can
change your thumbnail sort of scrub
through contacts and when you're done
you get a link right here that link is
HTTP so you can embed it directly into
your floor requests and whoever wants to
review your code gets a nice friendly
walk through and it doesn't matter about
time zones or anything fun like that
all right never again thanks that's
really encouraging so here's the link
again depending on the size of your PR a
walk-through video only adds about five
or ten minutes total to our set-up time
but it can potentially save the 30 to 60
minutes it might take to explain your PR
via slack or email I'm sorry or
scheduling a zoom meeting this is
especially useful when pairing
developers who have different schedules
for who a remote or who are not as
familiar with the engagement you're
working on all right two more tips
there's another give valuable feedback
sketch sketch is a free app we're going
directly into the tool here sketch is a
free app from Evernote it's probably my
favorite thing on all of these slides it
is loved by spark box for everything
from full-page decomps to quick design
edits to making memes of your coworkers
I use it daily here is an example I just
made this up sketch provides elegant
markup tools for drawing boxes adding
arrows and highlighting any necessary
changes you can just take a screenshot
and have at it that shift command for on
a Mac it took me a really long time to
learn that so now you don't have to
pretend you didn't know so here are some
real-world examples I pulled these
directly out of slack just didn't go
through them oh that one doesn't work
here's some muscles this is the best
joke in my slides and it's not even mine
all right so that's sketched by Evernote
you can just Google sketch you don't to
remember this whole link sketch works
well in the opposite direction I've
recorded it's an easy way for designers
to communicate desired changes with
developers say make this bigger reduce
the space here delete this link sketch
provides visual feedback for visual
thinkers all right last one one last way
to make your PRS friendlier is to be
friendly spot via github comments it's
no way to collaborate and let's face it
we know communication is very difficult
in tag
it doesn't communicate tone that's why
we invented emoji a co-worker of mine
Brian the one who wrote the really
awesome PR earlier also wrote an article
about this topic it's called stop giving
depressing code reviews the idea is to
give as much possible positive code
feedback as you do correction it's
really hard especially if you're an INTJ
like me you just go through and see all
the negative and you don't offer any
positive comments you can do it
so this is a picture Brian he knows I'm
including it instead of really going to
this topic I'm going to read you this
quote it says giving positive feedback
is an easy habit to adopt you're already
reading through the lines of code
looking for issues it doesn't take much
night it doesn't take much time to throw
in a nice or it looks great you see
something awesome say it so the link to
the full article is there but a few
positive comments make a huge difference
in the overall tone of your review
whether you're speaking with diviner
designers developers other team
contributors clients which are really
important so yeah be nice and that's
that's what I have hopefully at least
one of these tools can make the PR
experience more accessible for your
entire team and not just the developers
with healthy dose of empathy we can
improve the way our co-workers review
the code we write and as a result we
create smoother workflows increase both
speed and communication and make better
websites if you want to hear more about
spark box or the design system I'm
building please come find me I have
decals and some business cards it look
like ninja stars up here at the front
desk and that's it
you